let's get some analysis now from legal
scholar Jonathan Turley of George
Washington University Jonathan thanks
for being here thanks what struck you
from today's hearing well what was
really interesting was the different
narratives the fact is that the IG was
not likely to find that decisions were
based on bias but it's also not true
that he didn't find bias he actually
found a lot of bias it's just that he's
not going to assume that the bias he
found was the cause the decisions that
were taken by the FBI not his mandate in
other words that's right and so unless
someone was going to confess or help out
with a email detailing some conspiracy
there wasn't going to be a finding that
bias drove the decisions but the
Republicans were correct the the report
is heavily laden with very disturbing
statements of bias including from the
chief investigator so the question then
is that wasn't his mandate he's not
going to make those assumptions so where
you go from here the answer in the
Constitution is you go to Congress
Congress has an oversight duty to look
into this do some of these questions are
simply not answered you know for example
Lindsey Graham was correct to raise the
issue of Clinton's IT expert who was
accused of lying repeatedly to the FBI
scrubbing her server after being told it
was part of an investigation and
something that Congress was looking for
and took all these actions that would
have justified in most of our view an
actual criminal charge instead they gave
him immunity which at the time left all
of us just dumbfounded why you would
possibly do that those questions were
not answered because that's not the
mandate after reading the IG report and
seeing the testimony today the case for
obstruction of justice
well I think I tell you this I GE report
makes a difficult obstruction claim
based on the Comey firing virtually
inconceivable you know you have the this
Inspector General saying that Comey was
insubordinate that he deviated from
policies that these were serious
violations the FBI director echoed that
today those are all good reasons to fire
him so unless you're going to make
assumptions that Trump acted for every
wrong reason instead of the obvious
right ones it's gonna be real hard to
make out a criminal case there are other
teases of things to come another IG
report it sounded like several leak
investigations and an even an
investigation into commis personal use
of email and whether there was
classified material there yeah if I was
call me I'd hear a whistle on the track
because they're looking at his removing
these memos from the FBI which I have
said from the beginning is clearly FBI
material the FBI is indicated that one
might have had classified information in
it I can't imagine the Inspector General
looking then saying
okey doke that's fine you just feel any
time you're fired to remove any file as
you want and then leak them to the media
so that train is going to come down it's
not going to be good for combing let's
turn to the first story and the story
that's gotten a lot of attention what
the administration is doing what
Democrats are doing what Congress can or
should do on this this case with
separating parents and children along
the border now it's a really sad story
because as usual in Washington there's
truth and falsity on both sides
everyone's spinning this and in the
middle are all these kids the fact is
that the administration does not have to
separate the kids from from their
mothers that's a choice that's a policy
choice it's also true that this issue
has been forced by a change in policy to
treat these as criminal matters
something many citizens support I mean
Donald Trump was brought to power
because he was pledged to get tough on
immigration getting tough on immigration
means to switch from a civil or
administrative process to a criminal one
once you do that you have these type of
separation problems and so there is
truth on both sides here there are some
agreements and some laws that govern how
long and under what circumstances you
hold children but can the administration
keep these families together yeah I
think they could there is a there is a
choice that is made at the border
they're rich Lowry indicated it and I've
had a couple of weeks ago in which he
wrote the u.s. marshals take custody of
the adults when the children are held by
the HHS the prosecution of the adults
for illegal entry usually happens
quickly then if the adult wants to
return home she or he is reunited with
her child they're sent back together
where it gets more complicated is if a
migrant claims asylum trump
administration wants to hold migrants
pending adjudication of those cases if
they're released there's a good chance
they'll abscond but even if the cases
are handled quick
ie in a couple of months the government
has to release the children sooner
thanks to a 20 year old consent decree
and associated legal rulings it's just
one of the distortions that makes a
rational policy at the border impossible
when accompanying children from Mexico
across the border we can quickly return
them home an anti-trafficking law makes
it nearly impossible to do that with
unaccompanied children from Central
America basically as long as migrants
know that they can get in they will keep
coming and bringing their children on
this harrowing journey if they claim
asylum they're essentially choosing to
separate from their children yeah and I
think this is all due to that paradigm
shift when that when the administration
was treating this as a purely
administrative process not a criminal
one there were fewer complications that
arose once you shift to a enforcement
system a criminal one it magnifies these
problems but this law does create a
glaring conflict in this 20-day clock
running so you can release but then you
have this gap of these the mothers
moving on a different track from the
kids that's a legitimate issue that the
Trump administration wants to resolve
and you're talking a lot of kids it's a
lot of kids secretary Neilson said they
could go to port of entry is legal port
of entries and claim asylum and stay
together right this is dealing with
illegal border crossing yeah what is
unfortunate I think both parties are
playing chicken here but they're kids in
the car and so I think that everyone's
gonna have to take a breather rare time
and just get together and say let's get
this off the table it's it's not good
for this country it's certainly not good
for these kids
you know the images are horrible
Jonathan thank you very much thank you